six d'entre eux plusieurs blessés de
part et d'autre tous les communiqués
publiés
l'union nationale des syndicats de
journalistes la tête j'essaie de montrer
que le centre de moby est resté bloqué
pendant plusieurs heures par les forces
de police
alors que débute et de démontage de
l'antenne de la station de la cgt radio
quinquin
c'est une première intervention des
gendarmes mobiles avaient fait des
blessés samedi et dimanche
l'affrontement avec eric le premier mois
passé une délégation et permanents cgt
et d'élus du parti communiste est rendus
à la sous-préfecture en signe de
protestation
vers 11h temps la destruction de
l'antenne commencé à l'aide d'une grue à
l'intérieur de la mairie les forces de
police n'étaient ni le matériel mis à
l'abri il dit me disent utiliser pour un
électorat
pendant la durée de l'opération
nouvelle ré contenté de commenter
l'événement dehors malgré la présence
des gendarmes mobiles
la foule pékin à croire nombre
d'émissions radio quinquin même si elle
a conservé son accueil et les blue
silence une interruption qui a soulevé
des protestations notamment celle de
l'union nationale des syndicats des
journalistes